Wie es schon Tradition hat, blicken wir Anfang des Jahres mal zurück auf das Jahr im Rasenfunk. Das tun wir wie immer mit Frank, der hier mit dabei ist. Mein Name ist Max und jetzt kommt euer Intro. Das Programm der Rasenfunk.
Rasenfunk? What the hell is Rasenfunk? Da lach ich mir doch einen Arsch ab.
Echt. Alles bla bla bla ist das doch. Alles bla bla bla ist das. Das Tribünengespräch. So viel Community steckt im Rasenfunk, es ist nicht unser Intro, es ist euer Intro. Communismus at its finest, Uli Hoeneß gefällt das. Frank, schön, dass du hier bist.
Servus, Max. Heute vor allem selbstreferenzielles bla bla bla, um das Intro aufzugreifen.
Ja, inzwischen greife ich da inzwischen immer aufs selbe zurück, weil ich weiß, dass es so langsam Kultstatus genießt, dass wir hier ein bis zweimal im Jahr Wolf Fuss hören und danach dann Thomas Doll. Frank, wie geht es dir?
Exakt, das ist es nämlich. Es werden eh schon genügend Daten gesammelt und ja klar, es gibt zweimal im Jahr gibt es den Moment, wo ich mich ärgere, dass ich nicht sehen kann, wie viele Leute auf unsere, auf die Links in den Newslettern klicken, die wir rausschicken. Und an allen anderen Tagen im Jahr ist es mir aber egal. Und dann ist es eigentlich richtig, dass wir diese Daten nicht sammeln, auch wenn sie anonymisiert und alles und so weiter werden, weil wir eben grundsätzlich versuchen wenig Daten zu sammeln. Das ist schon in Ordnung so. Es muss auch solche Orte im Internet geben. Und vielleicht an der Stelle noch der Hinweis, weiß nicht, ob du es auch schon gesehen hast, solltet ihr von WhatsApp nicht zu Signal gewechselt sein, weil es bei Signal ein bisschen frickeliger war in der Vergangenheit, sein Backup zu sichern von allen Chats und Nachrichten. Das gibt es jetzt. Es gibt es jetzt genauso komfortabel wie bei WhatsApp. Ein Grund, weniger bei WhatsApp zu sein. Aber das ist jetzt nur ein ganz privater Take hier noch. Machen wir weiter mit einer Frage von Hakuna Matata. Er fragt einmal, ich denke uns beide, mal ganz klassisch, was sind die Jahresziele der Rasenfunk EMBH für das kommende Jahr? Frank, hast du uns eine Powerpoint mitgebracht? Ja, vor allem Powerpoint.
Nein, tatsächlich. Ich bin noch dabei an den KPIs.
Da muss erst noch eine Kidne hin rüber schauen.
Ja, genau. Nein, tatsächlich. Zieldefinitionen waren nie so mein Ding. Vielleicht, leider, vielleicht, Gott sei Dank, ich weiß es gar nicht. Aber es ist einfach nicht so mein Ding. Und für den Rasenfunk ist es ja auch tatsächlich schwer. Ich meine, natürlich, wir haben, glaube ich, schon öfter darüber gesprochen. Natürlich ist uns wichtig, dass der Rasenkunft Rasenfunk in Zukunft funktioniert. Natürlich würden wir gerne ein bisschen wachsen. Aber das ist jetzt nicht so ein Wachstum forever. Und nur maximales Wachstum ist gutes Wachstum. Sondern eigentlich eben nur, weil wir natürlich wissen, dass immer auch hinten was wegfällt. Jemand, der einen nicht mehr hören will, der vielleicht vom Fußball genug hat, der einen nicht mehr unterstützen will. Unser Wachstumsgedanke geht eigentlich in erster Linie aus einem Erhaltungstrieb heraus, würde ich sagen.
Und um steigende Kosten aufzufangen, muss man auch dazu sagen. Alle Arbeits- und so weiter, es wird konstant teurer. Das müssen wir halt auffangen jedes Jahr.
Genau, aber eben nicht aus so einem, naja, wir wollen ja genau in drei Jahren das doppelte Gehalt bekommen oder so.
Wir wollen jetzt nicht in die Börse gehen und müssen irgendwie unsere Zahlen noch schon frisieren.
Genau. Und unsere Gedanken gehen da immer, wir haben das ja in der Vergangenheit schon öfter besprochen, auch in Richtung finden wir vielleicht noch mehr Moderatoren, die was übernehmen können, um Max ein bisschen zu entlasten, um vielleicht auch Ideen umsetzen zu können und so was. Aber das ist ganz schlecht, als Ziel in ein Jahresziel zu packen, weil Moderatorenkandidaten wachsen nicht auf den Bäumen. Und wir haben es ja vorhin schon gesagt, da wir uns jetzt auch nicht an Trends orientieren oder an Statistiken, ist es auch ganz schwer, gezielt zu wachsen. Das ist einfach ein schwieriges Thema. Insofern würde ich sagen, es gibt keine Jahresziele.
Also wir wollen die 3% Steigerung, die wir bei den Gästehonoraren drin haben, die wollen wir als GmbH eben auch so grob haben. Wobei genau drei müssten es nicht sein, weil kann man ja dann umrechnen. Wir geben ja nicht 100% des Geldes für Gäste aus. Aber so ein bisschen mehr wollen wir dazu haben. Ich finde auch, dass es kaum fassbare Ziele dafür gibt. Vor allem auch, und das ist vielleicht ein Aspekt, den ich an der Stelle nochmal reinbringen kann, der Sportjournalismus sich gerade wieder verändert. Und das ist sowieso schon ein Transformationsprozess. Es ist nicht mehr so, wie wir vor elf Jahren, als wir vor elf Jahren angefangen haben, da sah die Welt auch im Sportjournalismus noch anders aus. Vieles ist seitdem besser geworden, meiner Meinung nach. Vieles hat sich auch im Podcastbereich getan. Wir sind nicht mehr der größte Fußballpodcast. Wir sind vielleicht der größte Independent-Fußballpodcast. Wobei man selbst da vielleicht noch Diskussionen sogar führen könnte. Aber generell verändert sich gerade im Sportjournalismus wieder so einiges. Also ohne jetzt in die Tiefe zu gehen. Aber ihr könnt mal die neuen Eigentümer von Sport1, könnt ihr euch mal zusammensuchen, was deren Ausrichtung betrifft. Ihr könnt mal verfolgen, was gerade RTL aktuell, jetzt dann wahrscheinlich, ich glaube heute sogar, tatsächlich verkünden wird. Ihr könnt mal angucken, was mit anderen Sportredaktionen so passiert ist. Ihr könnt angucken, was mit lokalen Tageszeitungen passiert, wie sich da immer mehr so ein Oligopol aus verschiedenen großen Verlagen herausbildet. Und ich kann euch aus Sicht von Freiberuflerinnen und Freiberuflern sagen, dass es wirklich ein rauer Wind ist, der gerade weht. Aus verschiedenen Gründen auch unter anderem den neuen Rundfunkstaatsvertrag, beziehungsweise jetzt eine Änderung, die jetzt dann in Kraft wurde, dürfen nämlich zum Beispiel auch die öffentlich-rechtlichen Sender auch im Sportbereich viel, viel weniger online machen. Es muss jetzt immer ein direkter Programmbezug hergestellt werden. Das alles haben wir der Lobby der Verlegerinnen und Verleger Deutschlands zu verdanken. Das heißt, für Freiberuflerinnen und Freiberufler, auch im Sportjournalismus, ist die Situation nicht besser geworden. Und ich kenne so einige, die damit ganz schön zu kämpfen haben, die auch eine große Ungewissheit haben. Ich kenne auch einige, die deshalb den Sportjournalismus oder den Sportteil in ihrem Journalismus und zum Teil auch den Journalismus generell an den Nagel gehängt haben. Das merkt ihr indirekt auch, wenn wir Probleme haben, Gäste zu finden. Wenn manche Gäste nicht mehr zu hören sind, dann hat es manchmal auch damit zu tun. Also da ist sehr viel gerade im Wandel. Umso dankbarer sind wir, dass es wie immer bisher in der Vergangenheit den Rasenfunk bisher gar nicht betrifft. Wir können unser Produkt einfach so weiter durchziehen, wie wir es mal aufgesetzt haben, weil wir anders finanziert werden. Aber in Online-Redaktionen generell und in Sport-Redaktionen auch, es geht ein großes Gespenst um. Und das heißt, Klickverluste durch KI, weil eben die Leute, die KI-Zusammenfassungen legen, aber nicht mehr auf die Seite klicken. Generell Reichweitenvermarktung funktioniert immer schlechter im Online-Journalismus und die Arbeitsbedingungen werden nicht besser. Auch durch manche Entwicklungen in den sozialen Netzwerken. Also das alles ist der Kontext, in dem letztlich auch die GmbH steht, in dem wir auch unsere Ziele definieren müssten. Und das ist dann mal wirklich komplex. Das ist anders als manch andere Dinge, die derzeit als komplex bezeichnet werden in unserer Welt. Das leitet vielleicht auch so ein bisschen über zum zweiten Teil der Frage von Hakuna Matata. Das kann ich jetzt kürzer machen. Er verweist unter anderem auf die Zweitligatur von Eva und Mark und auf die Kooperation bezüglich der Gruppe Amerika mit Johannes Eskiber. Und ob ich mir vorstellen könnte, mehr Sendungen abzugeben, das kann ich mir vorstellen. Aber es ist alles nicht ganz so trivial, weil man auch sagen muss, das Moderieren vom Rasenfunk ist noch mal was komplett anderes als Gast zu sein. Und zwar vor allem, was den Aufwand betrifft. Und das spiegelt sich noch nicht komplett in der Entlohnung wider. Wir haben da natürlich schon versucht, fair zu sein. Und wir wissen auch, dass alle, die bei uns moderieren, das so empfinden, weil das ist die Grundlage dafür, dass wir das überhaupt abgeben wollen. Aber es hängt schon viel dran, viel Aufwand. Dafür müssen dann die Moderierenden die Zeit haben und das auch machen wollen. Wir müssen es sein können. Grundsätzlich können wir uns da viel vorstellen, aber es wird also auf absehbare Zeit wird das schon so sein, dass einfach der Großteil des Rasenfunks wird moderativ von mir getragen werden müssen. Weil für mich ist es der Hauptberuf. Ich mache nichts anderes. Den ganzen Tag Rasenfunk rauf und runter. Deswegen kann ich auch alle Kommentare lesen, die ihr da draußen so zum Beispiel schreibt. Also das wird, wenn dann eher in kleinen Schritten funktionieren und das wird da nicht so den einen großen Schritt geben. Auch weil das glaube ich auch nicht, also es ist jetzt nicht so, dass ich hier zehn Bewerbungen pro Tag bekomme von Menschen, die sagen, hey, ich will auf jeden Fall mal ein Rasenfunk moderieren. Das muss man schon auch mal sagen.
Nichtsdestotrotz gucken wir trotzdem auf die Work-Life-Balance.
Ja.
Schönes Passwort von Max und unter anderem ist ja auch die Tatsache, zum Beispiel mit den Schwerpunkten. Als wir beim letzten Mal bei der Klausur zusammensaßen, beziehungsweise ich glaube, das war das Thema im Sommer, also beim vorletzten Mal, haben wir dieses Thema besprochen und haben ein bisschen darüber gesprochen, wie können wir vereinzelte Formate neu organisieren. Max hat es vorhin schon angesprochen, ich wollte es nur noch mal in dem Kontext erwähnen, was eben Reduktion angeht, auch um nicht die permanente ganz hohe Masse an Output zu liefern und auch ein bisschen inhaltlich auf das Wichtige zu fokussieren. Und das spielt natürlich auch beim Thema Work-Life-Balance ein bisschen mit rein.
Und das ist ja schon viel besser geworden. Also bei uns beiden ist es so, 2024 war ein wirklich heftiges Jahr in allen Belangen. Und eben auch ganz wesentlich, was den Rasenfunk angeht, 2025 hatte da schon eine ganz andere Note und eine ganz andere Temperatur für uns beide, auch wenn es so ein bisschen asynchron zwischen uns liefert. Du natürlich mit der Webseite sehr, sehr viel zu tun hattest. Aber also zumindest für mich kann ich sagen, war 2025 viel eher noch in einem Rahmen, der auch funktionieren kann auf Dauer. 2024, so wie wir da rausgeballert haben, aus verschiedensten Gründen, das wäre keine zwei Jahre mehr so gut gegangen.
Genau, aber das sind natürlich immer Sachen, das muss man auch dann immer ein bisschen selbstkritisch sehen. Und wenn man drin steckt in diesem Outputstrom und in diesem Mechanismus, dann sieht man es meistens gar nicht so gut. Und da haben wir aber Gott sei Dank geschafft, auch durch unsere Klausuren, die da immer wieder fast schon legendär sind für uns, das ein bisschen eben dann, naja, eben ich ein bisschen von außen drauf zu gucken, was Max angeht und dann ein bisschen zu korrigieren. Und da sind wir ganz froh, dass das jetzt so läuft, wie es jetzt läuft. Aber da steht am Schluss noch die Frage, Max, was sind in der Hinsicht die Lieblingsformate von Max?
Komm, sag's, sag's endlich. Ach, ich kann es nicht sagen. Es wechselt, ich kann es nicht sagen. Also natürlich macht mir die Ligatur Europa Spaß, auch wenn es natürlich schon schade ist, dass da nur Männer zu hören sind. Aber das hat auch Gründe. Also wenn ihr jemanden kennt, der weiblich ist und da eine Expertise hat, sagt es mir gerne weiter. Die, die ich bisher gefunden habe, die konnten sich das alle aus verschiedenen Gründen nicht vorstellen. Aber mir machen auch die Bundesligasendung so viel Spaß. Die Bundesliga der Frauen macht mir unheimlich viel Spaß, weil es da auch so ist. Also ich kenne, ich bekomme ja auch Feedback auf Sendungen direkt aus dem Bundesligan heraus. Jetzt nicht viel, also ihr müsst euch jetzt nicht vorstellen, dass hier Max Eberl anruft und sagt, Mensch, das ist aber richtig schön beschrieben, wie wir unser 2-0 geschossen haben. Das definitiv nicht. Aber es wird halt schon bei Vereinen gehört. Zum Teil zumindest. Und das hat bei der Bundesliga der Frauen noch mal eine andere Qualität als der Bundesliga bei der Bundesliga der Männer. Und allein deshalb macht mir dieses Format Freude, weil ich da ehrlicherweise manchmal auch einfach gespannt darauf bin, ob ich da eine Reaktion kriege nach Dingen, die wir in der Sendung gesagt haben, wie diese Reaktion auffällt und wie das quasi mein Hintergrundwissen zu dieser Liga verändert. Aber auch die Tribünengespräche machen riesig Spaß. Ich meine, ich würde, du kannst mich nachts um drei wecken, kannst sagen, willst du mit Jürgen Kalver drei Stunden sprechen? Und ich würde nicht mal nach einem Thema fragen. Ich würde sagen, okay, alles klar, lass mir noch eine Hose anziehen. Dann legen wir los. Also deswegen, es gibt nicht das eine Lieblingsformat. Das hört man ja hoffentlich den Sendungen auch an.
Und am Ende sind es Podcasts. Das sollte jetzt auch an der Hose nicht scheitern, eigentlich, wenn wir ehrlich sind.
Da hast du dann wohl recht. Die nächste Frage von du, die haben wir schon...
Hosenzwang ist aufgehoben, war mal früher so ein klassischer Spruch.
Ja, das versteht heutzutage keiner mehr.
Aus Twitter-Zeiten war das gleich, als Twitter noch Twitter war. Ach Gott, melancholisch. Ich glaube, den Post von Yuvi können wir überspringen. Yuvi, wir hoffen, wir haben es vorhin schon ausreichend erklärt, warum Gehälter und Honorare und Gäste Honorare quasi irgendwie doppelt aussehen. In den Zahlen. Dann kommen wir zu Ari Knizlo.
Ja, exakt.
Ich muss ja noch mich bemühen. Magst du den machen, Max?
Ich versuche, ihn zusammenzufassen, weil es ist ein längerer Kommentar. Er referiert auf das Tribünengespräch Nazis in Cottbus, das jetzt auch wirklich schon viele Jahre alt ist, und fragt uns, ob wir generell zum Rechtsdruck der Gesellschaft, der sich ja auch im Fußball bemerkbar macht, mal etwas machen könnten. Also er schreibt, er hätte gerne da eine, vielleicht sogar eine historische Einordnung. Er könnte sich das als Storytelling-Podcast vorstellen. Könnte ich alles auch und fragt eben, ob es dazu mal was geben könnte. Ich kann dazu tatsächlich sogar so halb konkret etwas sagen, und zwar, warum es in der Vergangenheit so selten weitere Themen zu diesem Thema gab. Also zu eben der Frage, wo drängen Nazis, vereinfacht gesprochen in den Fußballreihen? Und was kann dagegen getan werden? Wie ist das Ganze einzuordnen? Wie verhalten sich die Verantwortlichen? Es ist extrem schwierig, dazu Gesprächspartnerinnen zu finden. Ich hatte da zum Teil schon konkrete Zusagen. Ich hatte da aber auch dann schon unter der Maßgabe, die Stimme wird doppelt verzarrt, damit nicht nachvollziehbar ist. Dann, okay, wir sprechen dann im Nachhinein das Interview neu an. Und so weiter und so fort. Ich hatte zum Teil auch schon Journalistinnen und Journalisten, die aber, wenn sie in diesem Bereich sehr tief unterwegs sind, also nicht nur Feindbild sind und deswegen natürlich mit öffentlichen Äußerungen zurückhaltend sein müssen, die aber auch in der Regel komplett überarbeitet sind, weil das nur erschreckend wenige in Deutschland sind, die sich wirklich in diese Themenkomplexe richtig tief reinarbeiten. Deswegen, es gab schon mehrmals dazu so halbkonkrete Planungen, in einem Fall sogar sehr konkrete Planungen, die dann ganz kurzfristig eben abgesagt wurden und zwar für immer. Deswegen, es ist für uns auch ein wichtiges Thema, das wisst ihr ja. Und das wird auch aus dem Rasenfunk nicht verschwinden. Allein deshalb, weil wir auch an der Stelle sehr gerne nochmal sagen, wenn ihr wirklich nichts besseres zu tun habt, als die AfD zu wählen, wenn ihr wirklich glaubt, von dieser Partei seien Lösungen zu erwarten, die gut für dieses Land werden, dann möchten wir euch weder als Hörer noch als SupporterInnen, wir wollen mit euch nichts zu tun haben. Ich will auch keine Kommentare von euch bei YouTube lesen. Bitte sucht euch einfach viele andere Ecken im Internet, sind braun genug für euch. Und ich will jetzt nicht die Diskussion, sind alle AfD-Wähler Nazis führen, aber jeder der AfD wählt Nazis und dementsprechend hat er mit dem Wertekassett des Rasenfunk so gar nichts zu tun. Wir können uns gerne drüber unterhalten, warum ihr unzufrieden seid, aber die Lösung kann nicht sein, Nazis zu wählen. Das kann ich an der Stelle noch mal sagen. Und es wird auch sicher weiter Sendungen dazu geben, aber es ist leider tatsächlich schwierig. Es ist wirklich total interessant, da so seinen Fuß reinzuhalten in diese Szene der Journalisten.
Und auch wenn ich das jetzt nur aus meiner persönlichen Sicht sagen kann und gar nicht aus dem Hintergrund wie Max, was die Gesprächspartner angeht, ich glaube, es wird auch klar sein, für jeden, der die Welt beobachtet, wie sie sich jetzt im letzten Jahr entwickelt hat vor allem, noch mal verstärkt, dass das jetzt auch nicht leichter wird. Weil die Tendenzen sich immer weiter vor schieben in der Gesellschaft. Und das macht es nicht leichter, weil das Menschen entweder sich nicht trauen oder einfach nicht wollen, wollen wir mal über die Hintergründe gar nicht spekulieren, sich zu dem Thema zu äußern. Ich glaube, das wird jetzt erst mal so schnell nicht einfacher werden. Und um auf den Post im Forum von Arek Nizlo, ich finde keinen Weg, das flüssig auszusprechen, Arek Nizlo, zurückzukommen, ja, natürlich würden wir super gerne so ein Tribünengespräch machen und ich glaube, da steckt auch viel Stoff drin, aber ist eben schwierig ohne gute Gesprächspartner dazu.
Ja, und ein Stück weit auch, aber das liegt auch an mir halt der Anspruch, also so wie er oder sie hier schreibt, man hätte gerne quasi auch das Historische und die Einordnung und verschiedene Gruppen und das ist ja auch nicht schwarz und weiß in diesem Bereich oder in dem Fall braun und weiß, sondern da muss man ja auch gute Vorsätze, Max.
Du hast ja gute Vorsätze.
Ja genau, da habe ich mich jetzt auch gerade wieder dran gedacht.
Kurz noch mal dran erinnern, ist schon drei Minuten her, aber.
Ja ja, exakt, exakt, exakt. Vielleicht melde ich mich bei dem einen Experten, den ich da hatte schon mal. Da habe ich damals gedacht, da müsste ich eigentlich noch einen weiteren Experten und dann noch jemand aus der Fanszene und dann aber noch jemanden vom Verein, der sich dazu mal äußern kann. Und so ist quasi die Idee dann gestorben, weil ich sie zu groß gemacht habe. Vielleicht fange ich doch mal mit einem an. Ich nehme es mir vor. Jetzt haben wir es wieder gesagt. Also danke für den sehr guten Input auch. Also das war sehr schön zu sehen. Die nächste Frage hat der liebe Dux Kruk gestellt, auch Forums Power User und sie geht an dich, Frank. Behind the tech, warum war die Webseite mit 503 down? Also das ist eine Fehlermeldung an alle Hörerinnen und Hörer. Bad Gateway ist es, glaube ich, oder? Und wie aufwendig ist die Maintenance, also eben das Pflegen, eigentlich so im Durchschnitt der Technik? Tja, jetzt darfst du abnöten.
Die Maintenance ist tatsächlich gar nicht so aufwendig. Der Rasenfunk ist grundsätzlich relativ wartungsarm, was das technische angeht, also den Website-Teil. Abgesehen von Updates, die wir dann mal für zwei Jahre auslassen und dann Monate lang Arbeit haben, um den alten Code wieder in Schwung zu bringen. Aber das ist mal was anderes. Aber im Normalbetrieb würde ich sagen gar nicht. Der Fehler war tatsächlich auch gar nicht direkt mit dem Rasenfunk verbunden. Da laufen auf dem Server noch zwei, drei andere Kleinigkeiten im Hintergrund. In dem Fall war es, was mit KI zusammenhängt, was einfach schlichtweg eine Datenbank vollgeschrieben hat, mehr oder weniger. Im weitesten Sinne könnte man jetzt sagen, einfach Logs vollgespuckt hat, ohne dass es jemand, und dieser jemand bin ich in dem Fall, gemerkt hat, weil man natürlich sich immer vornimmt, alles schön mit Metriken und Warnungen zu versehen. Und wenn die Festplatte mehr als 80 Prozent voll ist, habe ich leider zu dem Zeitpunkt noch nicht eingerichtet gehabt, gibt es aber jetzt. Die Festplatte war voll. Das war die einfache Ursache. Ich muss ein bisschen sauber machen und dann war alles wieder gut. Und ja, Aufwand ist überschaubar, was die Wartung angeht. Das läuft Gott sei Dank alles relativ stabil. Und leider muss man ja auch ein bisschen sagen, die Website hat leider nicht die Wichtigkeit, die wir ihr gerne selber geben würden und die wir eigentlich auch in die Entwicklung gesteckt haben, weil halt nur mal ein Podcast vorwiegend im Podcatcher stattfindet. Und ja.
Also das muss man kurz sagen, es hat nicht die Wichtigkeit von eurer Seite. Und da seid ihr jetzt aber wahrscheinlich nicht die angesprochenen, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Sie wird einfach sehr wenig besucht von Menschen wie wir. Wir haben die Selbstseite konzipiert, um Menschen einen schnellen Überblick zu geben, was ist eigentlich der Rasenfunk, wie kann man den Rasenfunk unterstützen und wie finde ich mich in diesen Wust aus Sendungen aus fünf Formaten und so weiter zurecht. Und da haben wir sehr, sehr viel Zeit, Hirn schmalz, Liebe und Geld reingesteckt, um das eben wie wir finden, auf ein Niveau zu heben, das es im Podcastbereich vielleicht gar nicht so oft bei anderen gibt. Und müssen jetzt aber feststellen, so viele Menschen sind das gar nicht, die da in jedem Monat draufklicken. Also das Forum hat jeden Monat viel, viel mehr Views.
Du sagst es ja eigentlich schon. Wir haben tatsächlich durch einen Punkt vergessen. Wir haben nämlich eigentlich die Website auch so konzipiert, dass sie eigentlich gleich ein Podcatcher ist. Also sie ist ja auch als Player gut zu benutzen, vor allem weil man eben durch die Website surfen kann, während der Player läuft und so was. Dieser Punkt ist leider so ein bisschen, ich will nicht sagen für die Katze, das stimmt nicht, aber die Informationen und die Unterstützungsformen und so, das wäre wahrscheinlich, wenn wir heute nochmal neu über die Website nachdenken, mehr der Fokus als jetzt der Player und die technische Tiefe. Weil das tatsächlich eben leider auch in Spotify, aber auch in YouTube und auch in Apple Podcasts oder in Podcasts deiner Wahl, in Podcasts, in Overcasts und wie sie alle heißen stattfindet, was ja gut so ist, weil das ist ja alles, das auch, wofür wir Podcasts lieben und wofür wir froh sind, wenn wir gerade mal Zeit haben, was zu hören, einfach das Handy rausziehen zu können, Podcasts auf, auf Play drücken und fertig und nicht erst, ach, wie war nochmal die Website und dahin zu gehen und so. Das ist ja alles wunderbar. Insofern auch gar keine Beschwerde dahingehend, aber das ist eben so ein bisschen der Hintergrund und so, wie ich es gemeint habe, wenn ich sage, die hat leider nicht die Wichtigkeit, die wir, mit der wir sie geplant haben, kann man glaube ich so sagen und umgesetzt haben.
Beschwerde ja sowieso nicht. Also ihr hören und höre bestimmt ja, was ihr, was euch interessiert. Vielleicht wird die Bedeutung der Website auch für euch nochmal steigen. Sollten wir das irgendwann mit Transkripten zu Folgen hinbekommen. Aber da haben wir immer noch das Spielernamenproblem. Also wenn sich da draußen jemand damit auskennt, wie wir verlässlich es lösen könnten, dass gängige LLMs und andere mit den Spielernamen der Bundesligaspieler einfach nicht zurechtkommen wollen, wenn sie unsere Folgen transkribieren. Meldet euch bei uns. Bevorzug bei Frank. Ich leite ansonsten weiter. Ja, genau, wir haben es immer noch nicht von uns bekommen.
Gerne im Forum, schreibt mir eine PN im Forum, schreibt eine E-Mail über das Kontaktformular, was auch immer. Und schreibt auch gerne ins Forum, wenn ihr Feedback zur Website habt, auch jetzt zu den Neuerungen. Ich glaube, ich werde gleich, wenn wir fertig sind, mit der Aufnahme noch mal dort einen Post reinschreiben, kurz die Änderungen zusammenfassen. Und da könnt ihr dann mir gerne auch Feedback geben. Oder wenn ihr noch Probleme findet, die es bestimmt gibt. Ich habe da schon jetzt noch mal die letzten Tage ein paar Stunden rumgefallen an Kleinigkeiten. Aber da ist noch lange nicht alles perfekt. Oder wenn ihr auch sagt, Mensch, eigentlich würde ich mir auf der Website noch genau dies und jenes wünschen, gern raus damit. Wir können nicht garantieren, dass wir es umsetzen können oder werden. Aber über Input sind wir da sehr dankbar.
Aber wirklich. Ich habe eine Frage von Fipsa an dich, Frank. Nämlich bekommen wir Ed Helmi, falls ihr euch gefragt habt, wie man ihn im Forum anpingen kann. Unter Ed Helmi findet ihr ihn. Bekommen wir Helmi eigentlich mal wieder als Gast in einer Spieltagsfolge? Gegebenenfalls in der Superbowl-Folge. Na, Frank, wie schaut es aus?
Jetzt muss ich mich wieder outen. Als Fußballverweigerer wäre jetzt tatsächlich zu viel. Aber ich habe es ja, glaube ich, auch in den letzten Logbüchern immer schon mal gesagt. Mein Fußballinteresse ist tatsächlich der Rasenfunk. Also ich informiere mich über die Fußballgeschehenes über den Rasenfunk. Ich habe schon sehr lange kein ganzes Fußballspiel mehr gesehen. Muss ich zu meiner Schande gestehen?
Reicht deine Aufmerksamkeit Spanne nicht mehr, was? Du TikTok-Kid.
Ich, ADHS, Opfer, ja genau. Tatsächlich, ich weiß gar nicht, Aufmerksamkeit Spanne. Nein, natürlich nicht. Aber ich habe auch tatsächlich schon sehr lange kein Spielfilm mehr gesehen. Also Fernsehen ist tatsächlich aus meinem Leben ziemlich verschwunden. Fernsehen heißt jetzt YouTube. Sonst ändert sich nichts. Die Videolänge hat sich ein bisschen verändert wahrscheinlich. Ich schaue bei YouTube die Zusammenfassung der Sportschau Abonnenten an. Vorwiegend die von Bayern dann, weil es halt immer noch jetzt auch nicht, wenn es nicht mehr sonderlich emotional ist, aber immer noch so ein bisschen mein Verein ist. Und insofern, ich in einer Spieltagsfolge, das wäre tatsächlich ein ziemlicher Unfall. Ich könnte außer blöden Kommentaren nicht viel beitragen. Leider, ich finde es auch schade ein bisschen, aber der Rasenfunk wird weiterhin mein Herz und meine Leidenschaft bleiben. Aber der Fußball an sich ist schwierig. Funktioniert für mich nur noch sehr bedingt.
Du bist ja auch nicht alleine mit Frank. Also wir haben durchaus hin und wieder schon kleinere Probleme, Gäste zu finden. Vielleicht verändert sich dahingehend sogar noch mal was im Rasenfunk. Aber wenn das so käme, dann würdet ihr das eh als Erste erfahren, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Aber das Schöne ist ja, dass wir feststellen durften in den letzten 11, 12 Jahren, wir müssen uns nicht nur über Fußball unterhalten. Früher waren unsere Close-Urtaugungen so, dass wir die ersten 20 Minuten bis vielleicht auch manchmal gerne Stunden erst mal nur über Fußball geredet haben und dann, wie geht es dir eigentlich so? Und dann ging es zum Rasenfunk. Brauchen wir gar nicht, um sieben Stunden am Stück miteinander zu reden. Das ist auch nicht schlimm.
Brauchen wir gar nicht, um am Ende der Klausur sagen zu müssen, wir müssen langsam mal ans Einfahren denken. Ja, exakt. Und eigentlich wäre das Gespräch noch gar nicht beendet. Aber so ist es halt.
So ist es halt.
Genau. Max, hat sich denn dein Fan-Sein in anderen Sportarten durch den Rasenfunk verändert? Ist das weggefallen aus Zeitgründen? Fragt der Fipsa weiter, ist dein Blick auch im Football z.B. taktischer geworden? Schaust du dir die Strukturen woanders ebenso kritisch an? Das ist eigentlich, also wer Max kennt, das kann ja eigentlich gar keine Frage sein. Ich glaube, es gibt kein Thema, wo Max sich die Strukturen nicht kritisch anschaut, das mit Sport zu tun hat. Oder bist du irgendwo noch reiner Sportkonsument? Das ist tatsächlich eine interessante Frage. Gibt es irgendwas? Gibt es irgendeinen Skispringen oder so? Das schaue ich mir eigentlich gern an, aber das interessiert mir überhaupt nicht, was da so strukturell beim Deutschen Skiverband so abgeht.
Nee, also ich war ja sehr neulich beim Skispringen und... Nee, auch da schaue ich mir zum Beispiel an, welche Art vom Publikum da hingeht und welche Lieder da gespielt werden und welche Lieder da gesungen werden. Also ich bin halt einfach ein Dauernörgler. Also was ich noch konsumiere neben Fußball, ist hauptsächlich tatsächlich inzwischen American Football. Also ich bin immer froh, wenn die Rasenfunk-Sendung am Sonntag in der Nacht so früh vorbei ist, dass ich von der Red Zone noch möglichst viel gucken kann. Manchmal springe ich da auch zwei Stunden zurück. Oder natürlich auch gerne, wenn das Team spielt, das ich sehr gerne habe, das sind die Green Bay Packers. Aber es ist ganz schwierig, ein kritischer Sportkonsument zu sein und am American Football nicht ungefähr 1000 Sachen zu finden, die einen da stören müssten. Also ich würde mich da definitiv nicht als befreitsehenden Fan betrachten, auch wenn ich die Sportart mag. Und ansonsten muss man leider festhalten, ich glaube, ich habe das auch schon ein paar Mal hier erzählt, der Rasenfunk hat für mich andere Sportarten tatsächlich ein bisschen getötet. Denn früher war ich jemand, der immer alles geguckt hat. Also Handball, Skisport, da lief alles, lief einfach immer auf einem weiteren Monitor.
Realistisch betrachtet, wie soll es funktionieren, bei gefühlten 850 Stunden Fußball pro Woche?
Ja, vor allem, ich möchte jetzt einfach nicht mehr den, ich möchte einfach den Fernseher nicht mehr laufen haben. Also ich bin vielleicht einfach zu alt geworden dafür jetzt oder weil ich Kinder habe. Aber das tut mir auch manchmal für meine Töchter leid, weil ich weiß, wie schön das auch sein kann, einfach Sport sich anzugucken. Und man fühlt sich ja davon inspiriert. Also neben Fußball habe ich total gerne auch Basketball gespielt bei uns zu Hause im Hof. Und das hatte ganz wesentlich damit zu tun, dass ich Basketball gesehen habe und gesehen habe, wie man das so grob macht und so weiter und so fort. Aber ich will einfach nicht die ganze Zeit noch Sport laufen haben. Ich sehe dann auch viele Dinge kritisch, gerade am Wintersport. Ich kenne mich halbwegs gut aus in vielen Sportarten, weil ich dann über das Sportradio 360 zum Beispiel sehr viel konsumiere und natürlich halt in dieser Bubble unterwegs bin und mich eben rein theoretisch dafür interessiere. Aber es ist wirklich krass zurückgegangen und dass ich mal irgendwie, also Formel 1 zum Beispiel ist auch aus anderen Gründen komplett runtergefallen, dass ich da jetzt mal dann das letzte Rennen noch irgendwie nebenher laufen lasse, während hier auch schon Bundesliga läuft, hängt halt nur damit zusammen, wenn ich weiß, okay, das will ich jetzt nicht komplett verpassen, sonst ärgere ich mich später, weil ich gucke es nie im Real Life, auf gar keinen Fall. Ich gucke auch keine Zusammenfassung davon. Aber leider hat mein Sportinteresse durch den Rasenfunk echt so einen kleinen Schlag bekommen, weil ich nicht die ganze Zeit den irgendeinen Display laufen will, auf das ich dann immer wieder drauf gucke. Das ist manchmal einfach zu viel, vor allem nach so einem Wochenende.
Und das ist halt doch so, man muss den Sport auch sehen. Ergebnisse lesen und so, okay, dann weiß ich jetzt auch ungefähr, wie weit ist Bayern diese Saison schon wieder vorne und so. Aber ich weiß halt trotzdem nicht, wie sie spielen und warum sieht jetzt eigentlich Leverkusen gerade nicht so gut aus. Keine Ahnung, was auch immer. Also man versteht den Kontext. Klar, wie gesagt, ich höre den Rasenfunk und weiß es dadurch natürlich in der Theorie, aber es ist immer noch was anderes, das dann selber auch zu sehen. Und dann hört man natürlich auch so eine inhaltlich tiefere Berichterstattung wie beim Rasenfunk anders, wenn man auch gesehen hat, wie die spielen und was da gerade kritisiert wird. Und das fehlt einem eben, wenn man es nicht mehr sieht. Übrigens, ich will noch ganz kurz die Kurve kriegen, warum ich gerade den Wintersport erwähnt habe vorhin, weil ich bin nämlich eigentlich gar kein Wintersport-Fan. Ich bin selber nie Ski gefahren und habe mich auch nie sonderlich für Skispringen oder ein bisschen mal für Biathlon interessieren können. Kannst du dir vorstellen, warum ich jetzt gerade trotzdem vom Wintersport gesprochen habe?
Was, weil ich in Innsbruck war beim Skispringen?
Nee, hat nichts mit dir zu tun. Weil ich auch ein bisschen inspiriert bin von einer Creatorin, von unserer lieben Caro Kipper, die seit einiger Zeit bei TikTok unter dem Namen, darum wollte ich noch ein Shoutout loswerden. Caro kennt ihr alle als Stammhörer des Rasenfunks sehr regelmäßig, nicht nur bei den Nationalteams, aber auch da zu Gast. Die hat seit einiger Zeit einen TikTok-Kanal. Ich glaube, es sind noch gar nicht so viele Videos. Und wurde mir mehr oder weniger zufällig vorgelegt vom Algorithmus, schätze ich mal. Oder vielleicht weil sie dem Rasenfunk folgt, keine Ahnung. Auf jeden Fall Caro auf Eis nennt sie sich da und macht, finde ich, ganz fantastische Videos. Das hat mir sehr gefallen, obwohl wie gesagt Wintersport gar nicht so mein Ding ist. Aber ich finde einfach die Art und Weise, wie sie die Videos macht. Das Beste war eindeutig das mit der Lichterkette um den Hals. Caro, ganz liebe Grüße, wenn du das hörst. Super Videos. Ich bin treuer Abonnent und like jedes Video, das ich sehe. Einfach nicht nur um dich zu fördern, sondern einfach aus purer Begeisterung.
Das stimmt sehr gut, dass du das hier noch erwähnt hast. Ich bin ja auf TikTok nicht unterwegs. Deswegen habe ich mir das zwar mal angeguckt, als Caro es mir erzählt hat, aber es wird verlinkt in den Channels. Und ich weiß, dass Rasenfunke, Hörerinnen und Hörer auf TikToks unterwegs sind. Die haben uns jetzt zum Teil gefunden, als wir da selber noch aktiv waren. Also das vielleicht zu der Frage. Und dann haben wir noch eine letzte von Mich Boll, der fragt, wird es in Schwerpunkten oder in einem anderen Format auch ganzheitlich um Vereine gehen und nicht nur um deren Mannschaft? Und das ist tatsächlich eine höchst interessante Frage, denn ich habe die mir auch schon öfter gestellt in der Vergangenheit, weil wir ja in der Regel uns beschränken auf die Männermannschaft, es immer mal wieder aber Gäste gibt, vor allem natürlich Mara, die auf die anderen Abteilungen immer auch eingeht in den Folgen. Und ich bin ehrlicherweise da so ein bisschen hin und hergerissen, weil auf der einen Seite ist es natürlich schöner, den ganzheitlichen Blick zu haben. Auf der anderen Seite wird es aber da sehr bald noch mehr Überschneidung geben als jetzt. Also wenn du dann über die Wolfsburg Männer sprichst im Fußball, müsstest du eigentlich mindestens genauso lange über die Frauen im Fußball sprechen. Und dann hast du die anderen Abteilungen noch nicht besprochen.
Ich wollte ja sagen, was ist da mit der Badminton-Abteilung?
Exakt, exakt. Plus wir sind halt ein Fußballpodcast und ich kenne mich vor allem auch im Fußball aus. Und ich finde, es ist auch zu respektieren, wenn Leute auch durchaus manchmal Feedbacken, ehrlich gesagt interessiert mich das überhaupt nicht, was die Rollstuhl-BasketballerInnen dort machen. Auch wenn ich das natürlich schade finde, aber es ist auch stimmt auch, dass man das in einem Fußballpodcast nicht erwartet. Es ist jetzt die Frage, ob man sich da drin stören muss, würde ich jetzt sagen, ehrlicherweise auch nicht unbedingt. Aber ich respektiere dieses Feedback in dem Sinne, dass ich sage, ja, das kommt durchaus an dieser Stelle ein bisschen überraschend. Deswegen würde ich vermuten, lieber Michboll, dass das weiter so ist wie jetzt. Es ist dann einfach vom Gast abhängig. Wenn der Gast das möchte, dann rede ich da sehr gerne drüber und blicke auf andere Abteilungen, ohne dann natürlich so ins Detail zu gehen wie jetzt beim Fußball. Und wenn der Gast das aber nicht möchte, dann werde ich das auch nicht forcieren, denn das wäre ja auch komplett falsch. Also die Gäste bereiten sich eh schon wirklich außerordentlich auf den Rasenfunk vor, wie man ja immer hört. Wie jetzt nicht, dass die dann noch hektisch anfangen zu gucken, was die Tischtennis- und die Schachabteilung eigentlich so getrieben haben im letzten Jahr. Und das wäre ja dann auch nicht insofern authentisch, schwieriges Wort, aber gewinnbringend, weil wir leben von dem genuinen Interesse unserer Gäste, von ihrer Expertise und ihrer Leidenschaft. Wenn die da ist, und das ist sie im Bereich des Fußballs, deswegen laden wir sie ein, dann sind das fantastische Gäste. Und wenn die aber nicht da ist, dann passt das eigentlich auch gar nicht zu dem, was wir machen, weil eben alles, was wir tun, eben von dieser Leidenschaft für Fußball angetrieben wird. Deswegen wird es, glaube ich, weiter so sein wie bisher und dass es nicht geplant ist, aufzubrechen.
Er fragt ja auch nach eventuell einem anderen Format. Und ich glaube tatsächlich, mit dem Ziel ranzugehen, einen Verein ganzheitlich zu beleuchten, das würde tatsächlich den Rahmen springen. Und das würde auch so eine komische Erwartung bringen, dass man plötzlich über die Tiefen eines Vereines redet, wie Max sagt, was dann nur noch teilweise mit dem Fußball zu tun hat womöglich. Und was vielleicht aber wiederum auch mehr Aufgabe eines Vereins-Podcasts oder eines Club-Podcasts, wenn es auch dann ein Fußball-Podcast ist, vielleicht keine Ahnung zum 1. FC Köln, aber jetzt in der Tiefe über eine Mitgliederversammlung zu sprechen und was da in anderen Abteilungen passiert ist und so, passt sicherlich viel besser dahin. Wie aber Max sagt, wenn es im Kontext passt und wenn eben gerade Timara zum 1. FSV, MSV Mainz, FSV Köln, so geht es schon los. Zu erzählen, dann ist es natürlich super, weil es eventuell ja auch Kontext liefert zu dem, was beim Fußball passiert und so. Und weil natürlich gerade bei Bundesligavereinen der Fußball wahrscheinlich immer der massiv größte Teil des jeweiligen Clubs ist und so. Aber so als grundsätzliches Format oder Schwerpunkte darauf auszurichten, kann ich mir tatsächlich auch nicht vorstellen. Glaube ich, das würde nicht zum Rasenfunk passen. So wirklich.
Und ein letzter Gedanke noch dazu vor euch, liebe Hörer und Hörer. Die Gäste bestimmen Form und Inhalt des Rasenfunks. Und das merkt ihr manchmal auch, wenn ich zum Beispiel Gegenpositionen einnehme zum Gast. Wenn ich auf einmal ganz viel mit Statistiken um mich schmeiße und in der nächsten Sendung viel, viel weniger Statistiken von mir kommen, sondern eher andere Nachfragen. Also die Gäste lenken bewusst oder unbewusst, wie sie, also wie wir über den Verein sprechen, indem wie sie über den Verein oder das Thema sprechen, das wir im Rasenfunk haben. Und ich versuche dann, wenn ich Lücken sehe, die zu füllen, ich versuche argumentative andere Positionen aufzunehmen in meine Moderation. Gelingt natürlich mal besser, mal schlechter, aber auch das ist der Fall. Und es wurde noch nie ein Gast hier abgewirkt, wenn er gesagt hat, ich will jetzt aber noch was zu einer anderen Abteilung erzählen. Aber ich sehe es jetzt in dem Fall nicht als meine Aufgabe, dann eben nach Tischtennis zu fragen, wenn wir über Fußball in einem Fußballpodcast sprechen. Aber deswegen, die Gäste bestimmen letztlich das, was sie hier mitbringen. Und deswegen sind ja auch so viele Gäste so wahnsinnig beliebt bei euch da draußen, weil ihr dann schon so wisst, auf was man sich grob freuen kann. Nicht nur auf die Stimmen und die Kompetenz und auf die Witze, die sie mitbringen, sondern die haben ja alle so unterschiedliche Farben. Und insgesamt bildet sich dann eben das, was sich Rasenfunk nennt und jetzt schon seit elf Jahren zu hören ist. Frank, könnte man poetischer so eine Sendung zu Ende bringen?
Ja, nein, könnte man nicht. Aber ich wollte jetzt trotzdem noch ganz kurz was zu Mich-Boll sagen, weil mir an seiner Frage, mir ist gerade der Geist seiner Frage klarer geworden. Und ich glaube, wir sind ein bisschen dran vorbeigeschopft, weil wir jetzt immer Tischtennis und Badminton erwähnt haben. Er bezieht sich ja am Schluss und sagt da ja nicht nur um die Männermannschaft. Das heißt, er denkt wahrscheinlich auch ein bisschen an Frauen oder Jugend. Also vielleicht selbst, wenn man es beim Fußball belässt. Aber im Grunde gilt es, was Max gesagt hat, ja trotzdem. Weil wenn der Gast sich primär mit der Männermannschaft auskennt, dann macht es keinen Sinn, ihn jetzt zur Frauenmannschaft, zum Jugendbereich, was auch immer näher zu befragen. Das geht halt immer nur so weit, soweit der Gast es liefern kann. Egal ob Tischtennis, Frauenmannschaft, Jugendbereich, was auch immer. Auch Präsidium oder vereinspolitische Dinge, da kennt sich einfach nicht jeder gleich gut aus. Und wenn es Schwerpunkte sind im Bundesliga-Männerfeed, dann geht es halt nun mal schwerpunktmäßig um die Männerbundesliga. Und dann ist alles andere optional und schön, aber halt eben nicht zu erwarten.
Definitiv. Aber auch da muss man sagen, die neue Schwerpunktauslage hilft uns auch da, dass wir eben viel leichter so eine Extra-Schleife nochmal drehen können, weil nicht ein zweiter Gast darauf wartet, dass wir endlich noch über die restlichen drei Spiele des Spieltags sprechen.
Ja, ja, genau.
Absolut. Also auch dahingehend hat das geholfen.
Absolut. Und trotzdem tut es mir leid, dass ich jetzt die Poesie so gebrochen habe.
Ach, allein dafür gerechtfertigt, dass ich mich selber so gelobt habe. Das war ja total weird.
Das ist okay, das passiert ja immer viel zu selten.
Na, weiß ich jetzt nicht. Aber wir haben es jetzt nicht geschafft, wie Stay Forever in einer Stunde zu bleiben. Ich werde aber mal, falls euch interessiert, liebe Hörer und Hörer, sehr empfehlenswerter Gaming-Podcast, ich verlinke mal deren Folge, die ich jetzt zuletzt da gerne gehört habe. Außerdem werden natürlich in den Channels verlinkt. Also ich verlinke euch Manni und Tobi, wenn ihr euch mal gefragt habt, warum ist der Rasenfunk so schön, wie er ist. Und Steffi natürlich. Die drei sind der Grund dafür. Ihr kriegt natürlich den Link zur neuen Rasenfunk-Supporter-Seite, den ihr aber auch über rasenfunk.de leicht finden solltet. Kara auf Eis, bei TikTok, wird natürlich jetzt verlinkt. Und wenn ihr sagt, das Ganze mit der Aufteilung zwischen männlichen und weiblichen Gästen im Rasenfunk, das würde mich noch genauer interessieren. Der liebe Zaunpfahl hat es auch noch viel, viel genauer als nur so eine Gesamtzahl rausgelassen. Auch das werde ich verlinken, ist im Forum zu finden. Da könnt ihr euch das für die einzelnen Formate im Verlauf der letzten Jahre und so weiter angucken. Also wenn euch das interessiert, könnt ihr euch da noch richtig reinwöhnen. Das alles wird verlinkt und ich würde sagen, Frank, wir sagen danke, oder?
Sowieso, immer quasi. Also vielen Dank fürs Zuhören, fürs Unterstützen, fürs ins Forum kommen und da mitdiskutieren, im Discord mitdiskutieren, bei YouTube kommentieren. Wenn ihr in irgendeiner Form bei YouTube seid und uns gar nicht bei YouTube guckt, aber guckt vielleicht trotzdem mal vorbei, lasst mal ein Däumchen da, wie man das so schön sagt und macht das Plus weg und so, die ganzen modernen Dinge, die die Jugend heute so sagt.
Ich erkenne dich kaum wieder. Sehr schön. Tut das alles und dann bedanken wir uns in dieser Folge natürlich auch sehr herzlich bei einigen nach dem Zufall ausgewählten Nutzern, das in dem Fall Christopher Paul, Andre Mesut Mesi, Ostkreuzkicker Marcel und Sichtmonitor. Sie alle sind auf rasenfunk.de gegangen und haben uns unterstützt. Schaut euch die neue Homepage an, schaut euch unsere Unterstützenseite an und empfiehlt uns sehr gerne weiter und bleibt uns auch in diesem Jahr gewogen. In diesem Sinne, danke für eure Aufmerksamkeit, werdet oder bleibt gesund und bis bald. Ciao! Das war der Rasenfunk. Wir grüßen alle, die uns liebhaben.